hello it's seven o'clock this is sky
news breakfast these are our top stories
here this morning
calls for urgent help as millions of
households face being plunged into fuel
poverty with energy bills set to surge
by 80 percent
i can't tell you
oh i'm going to do it but
i like to
and a warning from the chancellor that
even those on 45 000
salaries could struggle to cope with
soaring bills this winter
i'm in south london to find out how
people here will cope as small
businesses say these price rises are
simply unsustainable
here in liverpool a second man is
arrested on suspicion of the murder of
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell
an affidavit reveals former president
trump took home top secret national
security documents to his florida
mansion
a warning from the ukrainian president
that the situation around the zaparisia
nuclear power plant remains precarious
and dangerous
the aaa issues an amber traffic warning
as the bank holiday getaway gets
underway
[Music]
carnival's return this weekend the
notting hill carnival is back on the
streets of london for the first time
since the pandemic
in sport ben stokes and ben folks put
england in a commanding position against
south africa
[Applause]
plenty of onset of settled rather
whether to enjoy this bank holiday
weekend but there are a few showers
around today
and coming up to quarter two we'll take
a look at the papers with the
journalists and author gemma forte and
broadcaster and writer edward adew
[Music]
hello good morning and welcome to sky
news breakfast the government and tory
leadership candidates are under
increasing pressure to set out plans to
help millions of households facing fuel
poverty with energy bills now set to
soar by 80 this autumn
yesterday the energy regulator ofgem
raised the price cap to
3549 pounds which experts have warned is
simply not affordable
but it's not only the most vulnerable
who will suffer the chancellor is
warning this morning that even middle
earners will be hit hard by the price
hikes
speaking to the daily telegraph nadine
zahawi said my concern is that there are
those who aren't on benefits
if you're a senior nurse or a senior
teacher on 45 000 pounds a year you're
having your energy bills go up by 80
percent and will probably rise even
higher in the new year it's really hard
skies business correspondent paul kelso
reports
we'll hear more actually from uh paul a
little bit later
we're going to hear more from madeleine
ratcliffe now because it's not just
families but a new poll has suggested
that a quarter of small businesses
say that their bills will be
unsustainable within a year madeleine
you're in southeast london aren't you
businesses there feeling concerned about
the winter ahead
morning morning anna yes they are it's
you know that 80
uh
rise in the price cap is obviously going
to squeeze not just vulnerable people as
the chancellor said it's going to be a
nightmare for houses households across
the country but spare a thought for
businesses who don't see their the price
of their gas and electricity capped at
all and that means that some businesses
have seen the cost of their gas and
electricity go up by more than 300 or
400 percent since february alone and so
this uh poll out this morning by youth
won't come as a surprise some of the
findings from that um yougov have found
that uh
over a quarter more than 25 percent of
small medium-sized businesses say that
these energy prices at the moment are
just unsustainable over the next 12
months and there's a real risk that they
will go out of business trying to pay
them five percent are already saying
that their energy bills are unaffordable
and for the rest how will they survive
they say there's no option but to pass
those energy costs onto their customers
through higher prices now the chancellor
is looking at support for businesses
perhaps a v80 or a business rate cut
like we saw during the covert pandemic
but there is a real risk that for many
businesses who did survive those
lockdowns they now will fold because of
this energy crisis
thanks very much indeed
so there's growing pressure on the tory
leadership candidates to set out exactly
what they'll do to help the millions of
households facing financial hardship due
to those soaring energy bills boris
johnson has pledged that whoever
succeeds him as prime minister will
announce extra cash next month to
support families but labour's warned
that the front-runner liz truss's plans
would leave four million families out in
the cold if further direct support is
only rolled out to people on benefits
well let's speak now to the chair of the
education select committee and rishi
sunac supporter robert halfon uh very
good morning to you robert half one
thanks for joining us here at this
saturday morning
so we're in an extraordinary situation
aren't we this unprecedented jump in
energy bills which we're all facing as a
nation up by 80 percent the energy price
cap
does rishi sunak have a fully costed
plan to deal with it and if he does
can we not see it
well you're right that the situation is
grim you've just been talking about
small businesses a fish and chip shop in
my constituency of harlow have seen
takings go down by 5 000 a month while
their energy bills have gone up from
1800 to 3 000 pounds a month my local gp
surgery his gas for the surgery is going
currently 10 000 going up to 24 000
a year and of course clearly this is
unsustainable
and that's why i think that uh what shi
sunak has done so far is when he was
chancellor is incredibly important
because
1800 pounds going to
uh sorry 1200 pounds going to 8 million
vulnerable
families everybody getting a rebate of
400 pounds that is working its way
through the system the fuel duty cut the
cut in national
insurance
attacks for 70 percent of households and
he has
said that
if he is elected as a prime minister he
will implement a significant
intervention in the same way that he
spent 37 billion pounds helping people
through the current crisis in terms of
the cost of living but don't we need to
know detail i mean it's quite vague what
he said he's promised help for the most
vulnerable
but also on businesses what's he said
about the exact help the business can
expect because they don't even have a
price cap
their prices the energy bills will go up
uncapped and they're really concerned
people need to make plans don't they so
the new prime minister will be in place
in in a week or so which is made it very
clear that he will set out a plan pretty
quickly in terms of how
um people are going to be helped with
with their bills whether it's small
businesses the public services um and uh
families i mean my own view and i'm
speaking personally
for myself is that what needs to happen
is that there needs to be a social
tariff for the most vulnerable and those
who are just about managing a small
business tariff from the energy
companies because the big businesses can
can pay these energy bills as the small
businesses are going to go under like
the fish and chip shop that i mentioned
in my constituency
and there also needs to be an essential
public services
tariff because i i gave you the example
of the gp surgery
my area is education i mean schools are
absolutely paying a fortune on their
energy bills what does that mean if
they're spending all their money on on
paying their gas and electric it means
less money for frontline staff for
teachers and support staff for doctors
for nurses whatever it whatever it may
be but i'm absolutely clear this is one
of the reasons why i'm supporting wish
you soon act because it would have been
very easy to promise tax cuts for big
business but we get the government's
going to face a triple whammy of cost of
living energy bills there's debt to pay
off 85 billion of debt interest alone
over the coming
coming year 2 trillion in debt overall
we've got the economy
to sort out public spending press
pressures uh as well so these things are
not easy but i think if you look at what
rishi sunak has done in the past
spending 37 pounds targeted support he's
very clear that he will make that
intervention if he becomes prime
minister next week okay
sorry sorry to interrupt the point i'm
making really is that we heard from the
regulator of gem saying and quite
unusual for regulators to speak like
this saying that the government needs to
act urgently and decisively the consumer
champion martin lewis is such an expert
in these issues has called it a
catastrophe plain and simple people
don't want to wait
that long shouldn't something be
happening right now
well they're absolutely right it is grim
i've got tyler constituents are working
seven days a week because they can't
afford to pay their bills otherwise it's
in place now we're not hearing more from
them are you frustrated because of these
concerns of people in your constituency
in a week's week or so's time we will
have a new government and very shortly
afterwards um
there will be a plan to deal with this
deal with this problem but absolutely i
agree there has to be a large-scale
intervention we have to focus on the
most uh vulnerable i don't believe it's
right to cut taxes for big business
because we have to raise the funds in
order to pay for this otherwise we'll
increase our our national debt and what
that means is that the cost of living
will
be even harder because interest rates
will go up mortgages will go up uh so
but there will be a plan in a week or so
time as soon as we have a a new
government but without doubt it has to
be a large-scale intervention
what the simplest quickest thing to do
to be to freeze prices
personally i speak personally i'm
open-minded on how this is done the
issue about freezing prices is how long
it lasts for and and also of course
you've got to look at the overall cost
because all these things are paid for by
the taxpayer
i think you need us and also it doesn't
necessarily um i mean if you're talking
about the party plan it doesn't help
businesses it doesn't help public
services like the nhs like schools
that's why my own view is i think there
should be a social tariff a essential
public services tariff and a
a small business tariff
um which the government would fund so we
would know that all those groups would
be protected
and the public services will be able to
spend money on frontline services small
businesses wouldn't go under and those
who are struggling with their energy
bills would have significant help
how great is the risk do you think that
schools
may not be able to stay open during the
winter because of the costs
i think schools will be able to stay
open they must stay open i thought that
uh
i was utterly opposed to schools closing
during lockdown for most pupils i
thought that was catastrophic and has
damaged our children's lives
sadly for many many years to come
um but
there will have to be a uh an
intervention in terms of our public
services schools the nhs uh policing uh
essential public services because all it
means is that
these public central public says or we
spend money spending money on their
energy bills rather than spending money
on frontline frontline services and i
want my schools to be able to spend
money on teaching staff support staff
and getting young people on the ladder
of opportunity and
absolutely essential this is why it is
going to be a huge large-scale
intervention that is needed but it's got
to be sustainable and it's got to be
properly accosted as well so it doesn't
uh increase our national debt by
too much because otherwise that will
cause other problems down the road
a huge intervention needed as you say
and as soon as possible and people need
reassurance as we've covered
would it have been better for the
country if the leadership contest had
been shorter so that people could just
get on with the job
i think there are arguments for and
against that um yes in some ways i think
um it would have been good to have a new
prime minister pretty quickly but on the
other hand you're choosing a prime
minister and i think it's right that
um these candidates go around the
country uh speaking to members but also
going to the commun local communities
and all and doing uh big media events
like sky hustings for example which
they've done because then i think the
public gets to know them the
conservative party members get to know
them they're properly tested so their
arguments for and against but i will be
absolutely glad when it's over we
desperately need a new government we
desperately need a
a proper plan of intervention to help
people with cutting the cost of living
and getting to grips with the other
problems facing our public services
as well and i hope very much that um
whoever becomes leader and i hope it's
rishi sunak but whoever becomes leader
will implement those plans pretty quick
well yes and just a quick word on
yesterday when the announcement came out
big announcement from off gem seven
o'clock yesterday morning normally you'd
have wouldn't you a government minister
in the television studios is
it traditional answering questions
coming under scrutiny about what the
plans were we didn't see anyone we
didn't see either of the leadership
candidates either yesterday
were you surprised by that at a time
when people need reassurance when
they're worried about their bills
i was on the media stand back venture
but uh
perhaps it might
i think for the government figures it
might have been um helpful for a
government figure to comment on this i
think the team sahari the chancellor did
make a statement uh later on in the
in the morning i think that's right but
i i'm someone who believes in uh
transparency and scrutiny and i think
from the media and i think that's a good
thing
okay well robert half on we really
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much for coming on the show
to other news now and police in
liverpool have arrested a second man on
suspicion of the murder of nine-year-old
olivia pratt corbell the 33 year old has
also been arrested on suspicion of two
counts of attempted murder
aerial footage has also been released
showing the arrest of another man who's
36 in a separate raid on thursday night
he was also arrested on suspicion of
olivia's murder and two counts of
attempted murder
well our correspondent fraser ward is in
liverpool and joins us now so some
developments in the last couple of days
in this investigation then fraser
uh good morning anna yeah it just shows
how fast moving and fastly quickly
evolving this uh investigation is less
than 72 hours
after the shooting of olivia in her own
home here uh on monday evening they made
that first arrest 36 year old man
arrested on suspicion of her murder and
two counts of
of attempted murder and then less than
24 hours after that in a street only
about half a mile or so away from here
armed officers affecting the arrest of a
second man a 33 year old man this time
we believe that he was arrested in the
street he wasn't arrested in a property
but that arrest carried out again by
armed officers and he is now at a police
station in liverpool currently helping
officers with their investigation now
the the officers leading this
investigation say that they still need
to build up what they refer to as a
strong evidential picture in order to
bring those responsible for olivia's
death to justice and as such they're
still appealing for people to come
forward with any information that they
can whether they have cctv footage dash
cam footage uh anything that might help
police build up a complete picture as to
exactly what was happening in and around
this area on on monday evening before
olivia's death and in the the moments
and potentially the hours after that as
well so they're still appealing in
particular for information about a
dark-colored audi q3 car we know that
that was the car that took joseph knee
to hospital joseph knew the intended
target of the attack he was the man who
first forced his way into olivia's home
followed by the gunman his associates
then chose to take him to hospital
leaving olivia dying on the floor in the
in the front porch the front entrance of
her own home so police have identified
that driver and spoken to him no arrest
was made there they've also identified
the man who was with joseph knee when
the attack started here on monday
evening they've questioned him and still
no arrest has been made there no charges
brought so the investigation is still
continuing at pace two arrests within
the space of 24 hours investigations
here at the scene will continue but in
the meantime officers will continue to
question two men now a 36 year old
arrested on thursday evening a 33 year
old arrested yesterday afternoon both on
the suspicion of murder of the murder of
olivia and also on suspicion of two
counts of attempted murder
fraser thanks very much indeed
now former president donald trump took
highly classified documents home to his
florida mansion after leaving the white
house including 25 marked top secret
that information was contained in a
legal document giving the reasons the
fbi raided the former president's resort
of mar-a-lago earlier this month mr
trump has responded calling it a public
relations subterfuge david blevins
reports from washington
the decision to search the home of a
former president was unprecedented the
decision to unseal the affidavit which
led to the operation highly unusual
21 of the 38 pages have been heavily
redacted to protect witnesses and the
integrity of the investigation
the affidavit reveals that of 184
documents handed over from mar-a-lago
last january 25 were marked top secret
and they suspected there were more
mar-a-lago
is the furthest thing from a secure
facility dennis aftergot a former
federal prosecutor said keeping
documents there could have caused great
harm among them are
documents marked
hcs which means
human intelligence sources
that can be
american
foreign intelligence
assets undercover in foreign countries
whose
disclosure could easily result in them
being killed how would you anticipate
president trump's legal team responding
to what has been revealed today his
apparent strategy in what he has filed
previously has been the political
approach
not the legal approach
the legal approach would be
keep
your mouth
shut
president trump described the document
as a total public relations subterfuge
by the fbi and the department of justice
in a pre-recorded interview just
released he continues to claim the
search of his home was politically
motivated
they brought many many fbi agents in all
right before the midterms
and all when i have the best poll
numbers i've ever had this is a
political attack on our country
despite the redactions this document
does shed more light on the
investigation into claims president
trump mishandled classified information
by taking documents with him when he
left the white house the department of
justice says the facts of this case are
particularly compelling and it acted
because it was concerned steps may be
taken to frustrate the investigation
with the fbi under threat and the
political temperature continuing to rise
authorities really must feel they have a
case worth pursuing david blevins sky
news in washington
also making the news this morning as the
last bank holiday weekend of the summer
begins drivers are being warned to
expect delays on major routes the aaa
has issued an amber warning and expects
traffic to peak between 10 am and 4 pm
with a mixture of day trips festivals
and sports fixtures causing increased
congestion it says nearly half of the
uk's drivers are going to hit the roads
over the course of this weekend
amateur gardeners will be banned from
using peat-based compost in england from
2024. the government announced a new
measure to protect the uk's already
severely damaged morelands
peatlands are the uk's largest carbon
sink host to some of the most threatened
wildlife they also filter water and
prevent flooding
a car used by diana princess of wales is
going on sale at auction today expected
to fetch a six-figure sum the car is
believed to be unique as the first and
only black ford escort rs turbo series
one the car was driven by diana from
august 23 1985 to the first of may 1988.
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky has warned the situation around
the zaparica nuclear power plant remains
precarious and dangerous
two out of six of the nuclear plants
reactors have been reconnected to the
grid following days of russian shelling
that led to the nuclear power plant the
largest in europe being disconnected for
the first time in its history
i want to emphasize that the situation
remains precarious and dangerous
any repetition of yesterday's events any
disconnection of the station from the
grid or any actions by russia that could
trigger the shutdown of the reactors
will once again put the station one step
away from disaster
that is why it is essential that the
iaea
mission arrives at the station as soon
as possible and helps to keep it under
permanent ukrainian control
a record heatwave is continuing to cause
huge damage in drought-stricken south
china these contrasting satellite images
taken in august 2021 and august this
year show the ongoing drought has
reduced china's biggest freshwater lake
to just 25
of its usual size
the lake waters dramatic decline has cut
off irrigation channels in one of
china's key rice growing seasons
authorities are now carrying out
artificial precipitation operations
firing rockets and flying meteorological
drones to bring rainfall to the affected
areas
let's start at old trafford and this
fella
centuries by ben stokes and ben folks
have put england in complete control of
the second test against south africa the
england captain reaches 100 just after
the t interval it's his 12th test
century and his fourth against south
africa he made 103 in a stand of 173
with folks
folks then went on to complete his
century it was 113 knot outs when
england declared on a 415
for nine with a lead of 264.
in reply south africa closed on 23
without lost 241 runs behind the tourist
lead the three match series one nil
relief um and yeah just overjoyed
obviously like getting a test hundred um
going to my first game and then a little
bit overweight and realize how hard they
are to come by so i think i celebrated
this one a bit more
phil gets today's premier league news
that former england and manchester city
striker ellen white has revealed that
her decision to retire was accelerated
due to suffering a punctured lung during
an acupuncture session last year white
was recommended acupuncture after
returning from the tokyo olympics with
back spasms but the trauma she
experienced during and after the
treatment hastened her decision to
retire after england's successful euros
campaign
manchester united traveled to
southampton in the first of today's
seven premier league fixtures united
manager eric tenhark is looking to build
on their win against liverpool last
monday
it's about transition it's about
running it's about battling and fighting
and then we have to make it our game so
it's a real challenge for us to do that
live for manchester and klopp's not
overly concerned about their start to
the season they're still looking for
their first league win of a campaign
before today's game against bournemouth
we understand the situation i have a
good a sense that our people understand
the situation as well and so i
i can't wait to create a special
atmosphere then fill together
team and crowd
yeah
to make things happen
in the championship olympia scored his
first goal in 43 games as leaders
sheffield united drew 1-1 with luton
carter morris scored for luton after
nine minutes
[Applause]
but united equalised early in the second
half and mcburney was booked for his
exuberant celebrations in front of the
united fans we can't blame him really it
puts united two points ahead of watford
this morning
[Applause]
the formula one season returns in
belgium this weekend after a summer
break and defending champion max
verstappen and charles leclerc will
start at the back of the grid the
unusual position they find themselves in
is due to receiving engine penalties
verstappen leads the world championship
by 80 points and was quickest in
friday's second practice at spa practice
three starts at 12 o'clock on sky sports
f1
let's go to golf and zander chouflay
produced a brilliant finish to
drastically reduce scottie scheffler's
fedex cup advantage heading into the
weekend at the season-ending tour
championship chauffeur is now just two
stroke strokes behind scheffler a
brilliant eagle on the 18th allowing him
to card a 7-under 63 which takes him to
under for the tournament
in atlanta by the way
in the super league wigan maintain their
100 winning record at home this season
they beat their big rivals and super
league leaders in helens 30 points to
10. bevan french went over with two of
their five tries
at the dw
[Applause]
and tyson fury's plans to retire could
take a u-turn we sort of knew they were
didn't we after he informed me wbc that
he wants to continue fighting the
british heavyweights who holds the wbc
world title now wants a potential
undisputed world heavyweight
unification fight with alexander usyk
after he defeated anthony joshua last
weekend fury initially retired after
defeating dillian white in april
now let's build up to this weekend's
premier league games over on sky sports
news coverage of day three of the second
test starts at 10 15 on sky sports
qriket there's f1 later on and i'll be
back in a nice time
handball handball
handball
you're watching sky news breakfast do
you stay with this coming up as people
take to the streets for manchester pride
this weekend we'll talk to the head of
sexual health at lgbt foundation as they
try to raise awareness about monkey
parks
let's turn our attention to something a
little bit lighter now and after two
years of covert disruption notting hill
carnival is finally back
expect streets filled with dances
costumes colours and a load of jerk
chicken all part of the london street
festival that celebrates the uk's
caribbean community our reporter sherman
freeman powell went to find out more
this summer caribbean carnivals across
the country finally got back on the road
celebrating the culture and
contributions the caribbean islands have
made all over the uk
and in manchester it was extra special
marking 50 years since it all began
it was essential because as a
marginalised community that came
together 50 years ago anyway
to show how it's grown and diversified
and that
as a people as a caribbean people our
heritage culture
matters
it was it was massive
manchester saw thousands but london is
expecting millions and preparations are
almost complete
[Music]
costumes like these are made months in
advance and dance moves perfected
c has been designing costumes from her
flat all summer hard work but worth it i
think it's important because it's been a
really difficult time for our
communities i think hope it's hit our
communities more than maybe other people
and um
and i just think it's the time for
everyone to get together you know a lot
of people are still quite nervous about
going out but it's just a way for
everyone just to kind of let go of all
their worries and just
um i don't know it's a feeling of
freedom isn't it and that's what
carnival is about i think as well this
weekend sound systems will boom the ear
will be filled with the sweet smell of
jerk chicken and millions of hips will
be swaying down these streets after
three long years organizers hope it's an
event everyone can enjoy a priority for
police too
this year at carnival we are going to
have safer spaces
we're working really closely with
partners around safer spaces and these
are places where women and girls if they
feel unsafe or they're uncomfortable or
they need support they can come to those
safer spaces
for us to
listen to their concerns and investigate
those concerns
the police aren't the only ones getting
ready for the storm of celebration about
to hit west london it may be quiet now
but up to 2 million carnival goers are
expected to turn up this weekend dancing
and partying until the city shakes
shaman freeman powell sky news
well people in manchester will take to
the streets this weekend to celebrate
pride but many are worried about the
recent rise of monkey parks health
bosses have issued special advice ahead
of the event while organizers see it as
an opportunity to raise awareness about
monkey parks
joining me now is lauren duffy who's
head of sexual health at the lgbt
foundation very good morning to you so
there has been a lot of concern around
monkey parks hasn't there
what's your message to anyone that's
heading to pride who might be worried
so what we're asking people to do this
weekend is to check themselves for
symptoms before they go out
if they're feeling unwell in any way or
they think that they might have monkey
parks then
stay home contact 111 or their sexual
health clinic
and then if they're out for the weekend
and they're having new sexual partners
just make sure they're
changing exchanging details with them so
that if anybody becomes unwell
afterwards you can get in contact
and
will most people
have been vaccinated how difficult is it
at the moment to get hold of a vaccine
so some people have been vaccinated but
those that have been vaccinated have
only had one dose so far and it's
recommended that there are two doses
we're also
in a period of time at the moment where
we know that there will be
more vaccine coming into the country in
september but there is a bit of a gap
so um it's it's it's probably
useful to remind people as well
that
whether you've been vaccinated or not
you're not you're not fully protected
from monkey park so it's a good idea to
take precautions
and what are the symptoms they should
look out for and
if they do get symptoms how concerned
should they be how serious can it be
so
monkey parks is a viral infection which
essentially means that lots of the
symptoms are classic viral symptoms
things like fatigue
and fever
but actually the main symptom that we're
talking about with monkey parks is
ulcers or blisters and people might have
one or more than one and they're usually
um
on their face or their hands or their
genitals
it can be quite painful um for the
majority of people they they probably
don't need much treatment if any um
but of course people people want to
avoid the pain and having an infection
if at all possible
and latest figures seem to suggest that
cases are coming down is that a sign
that the outbreak's slowing down do you
think is there cause for some optimism
here
potentially but we're always slightly
behind with numbers remember because
there's there's a window period between
infection and showing symptoms
um so it's i think we need to keep an
eye on the data but it's also while
we're talking about that data really
important to mention that this is a
relatively small outbreak still although
we'd want to do everything we can to
prevent it from spreading we are still
talking about 58 cases today in
manchester
so i don't want people to be
overly panicked or particularly worried
about this and let it impact on their
mental health or their well-being
okay well um messages
heard loud and clear lauren duffy thanks
so much and are you heading there
yourself later today i am i am
great have a have a really good time
enjoy thank you
so let's go through the morning papers
again here to review them today are the
journalists and author gemma forte and
the broadcaster and writer edward adew
welcome back to both of you
we i looked at the front pages didn't we
in the last hour all preoccupied with
the cost of
uh living crisis and the energy price
cap which no doubt will filter into some
of these stories but we've delved inside
and you found a few different things to
talk about um edward you've spotted a
story inside the guardian the guardian
says that they
have seen
an official inquiry and know the results
of it so what are they suggesting is is
going on here
so it's a um a draft of a government
ordered report that has found that city
khan wrongly ousted the
former um met police commissioner
christopher dick now the findings come
from the former chief inspector of
constabulary and it more or less says
that um excuse me that
would be that dick was um president dick
was fairly untreated and branding the
mayor's actions and decisions the
decision-making is irrational and
unreasonable now sadiq khan has um
fought back and and
his consulting lawyers and said uh he
believes that the report to be biased
and factually flawed and to quote um the
report also says that the the treatment
was oppressive and that she was placed
under on unfair pressure now he sadiq
khan has wrote a um
a letter to a pretty patel and said that
um
tom winters publicly uh championed
christopher dick now it seems that an
issue which we thought would have
possibly have been put to to bed because
obviously a new commission has been put
in place it still seems to be escalating
so
in terms the beef whether there was any
beef between um sadiq khan and
christopher dick i mean this report is
clearly stating that you know
it um she was ousted
sadiq khan is saying it's a bit of a a
tick for attack between the report and
what khan is saying so it'd be
interesting to find out find out that
the the true findings and as to
what actually took place and whether the
claims of the report whether any of the
claims are actually true well that's
right we'll have to we'll have to wait
to find get more clarity on that but
clearly a bit of a row going on there um
jimmy you're taking us inside at the
guardian as well and this is the
response by president macron to liz
truss's comments about him um at a
hustings earlier this week
that's right she was asked and i would
say it's a dubious question in the first
place she was asked macron friend ortho
there was hesitancy she was sort of
giggling and then she made some comment
about oh i'll judge him on his actions
which has sort of blown up on twitter um
and so it was put to macron you know
what what he thought about these
comments which in my view are at best
inelegant and at worst sort of a bit
moronic and xenophobic
and he said i wouldn't hesitate to call
britain and ali ally he pointed out you
know that if you're an ally or an enemy
you know there isn't a neutral sort of
position there and he also said the
united kingdom is a friendly nation
regardless of its leaders sometimes in
spite of its leaders it's not diplomatic
and it's ludicrous the french are our
nearest neighbors they are nato allies
there shouldn't be any reason to
hesitate with that question and it
doesn't bode well um in terms of
diplomacy going forward if she's going
to be our future prime minister yeah and
i'm not sure if we've seen her talk
about
why she said that she may well say yes
france of course is a friend i was
talking about macron i don't know she we
haven't heard it'd be interesting to see
if she says more on this at a later date
isn't it and
edward inside at the mail um it's a bank
holiday so the traffic is going to be
bad it's essentially the main message is
going to be bad oh there's a main
message um we've obviously the ongoing
issue with some flight cancellations the
issue with engineering works no one
likes to hear that term or that
reference engineering works with some i
think charing cross station is closed
the um the west coast main line i think
there's going to be restrictions or this
um there's certainly going to be some
restrictions in place we've got reading
and leeds festivals we've got notting
hill carnival you you just mentioned and
you spoke to um you spoke to your guests
about manchester pride lots going on
it's the last
technically it's the last bank holiday
before christmas uh it's the last time
where people can kind of go and enjoy
themselves but there's going to be
gridlocks i mean apparently it's going
to be literally over 10 10 million
people you know on the roads um
i was in east london yesterday and
noticed that the people had
really decided to uh leave early and to
to go on their travels and um
it's probably it's set to get worse over
the weekend so my advice is i'm not a
travel expert
take time out and don't don't get
stressed on the road because i was
stressed last night i mean a 40-minute
journey nearly took me two hours oh
that's the worst isn't it when you're
just not moving in traffic um i can't
believe you said the word christmas
though but i'm going to move on from
that
oh
don't say it's the end of summer i can't
get my head around that that's um
doesn't they're thinking about and gemma
let's take a very quick look inside the
eye next um we said we probably would
come back to the cost of living crisis
because it's dominating the papers
you've picked out a story that reflects
on what it might mean for schools
that's right as you say this is all
spilling into uh the middle of the
newspapers as well it's on every front
page and yes schools are facing some
really difficult decisions teachers
haven't had a pay cap for a long time
and obviously they're facing rising
costs and what schools are actually
looking at is how are we supposed to
heat the school we cannot afford it on
our budget their budgets haven't
increased so again another argument
perhaps government should have been
recalled specifically for instances like
this um so they're gonna have to surely
cap the bills for schools we cannot have
our children learning from home again
which would be the alternative for two
days a week i simply cannot contemplate
that for them it's you know they've all
lived through covid and that they i
think that that is something that people
would not put up with frankly yeah well
hopefully we'll get the plan soon from
from a new prime minister once they're
installed and we've only got about 20
seconds can you sum up electric cars in
20 seconds it's inside the eye
well anna the issue we're talking about
cost of living
prices are set to go up at hubs i have
issues at the moment i've got an
electric car there's not many hubs that
work in places like bedfordshire and
with this in mind i think the incentive
is to try and get people to switch to
electric cars if the prices are going to
go up then it's certainly going to put
people off there has to be a
has to be a plan in place to try and
convince people electric cars do work
prices may have to go up but it has to
be a counterbalance so okay we're out of
time edward and gemma i'll see you again
next hour thanks both very much indeed
[Music]